♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
IT HAS BECOME CLEAR THAT A
LONG STRAL OF NEGLIGENCE LED
TO THE VALENTINE'S DAY
SHOOTING IN PARKLAND,
FLORIDA.
SCHOOL OFFICIALS FAILED, SO
DID THE FBI.
BUT BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF
SCOTT ISRAEL HAS A
DISTINGUISHED RECORD OF
EXCEPTIONAL INEPTITUDE AND
ARROGANCE.
UNDER ISRAEL'S LEADERSHIP
BROWARD DEPUTIES IGNORED
REPEATED WARNINGS ABOUT
NIKOLAS CRUZ'S VIOLENT
BEHAVIOR.
THE DEPARTMENT RECEIVED AT
LEAST 23 CALLS ABOUT CRUZ OR
HIS FAMILY.
AND ONE CALL LAST NOVEMBER A
TIPSTER SPECIFICALLY WARNED
THAT NIC LAZARUS CRUZ WAS,
QUOTE A SCHOOL SHOOTER IN
THE MAKING WHICH TURNED OUT
TO BE SADLY TRUE.
SHERIFF ISRAEL DID NOTHING.
UNDER ISRAEL'S LEADERSHIP
THE DEPARTMENT ENTERED AN
AGREEMENT TO DRASTICALLY
REDUCE STUDENT ARRESTS.
THE GOAL WAS TO ELIMINATE
THE SO-CALLED
SCHOOL-TO-PRISON PIPELINE
WHICH AT THE TIME WAS A TOP
PRIORITY OF PRESIDENT OBAMA
AND ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC
HOLDER.
THE EFFECT WAS A DISASTER.
CRUZ MIGHT HAVE BEEN
ARRESTED AND CONVICTED OF A
CRIME IF IT NOT FOR THAT
POLICY HE WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO BUY A GUN.
ONCE THE PARKLAND SHOOTING
BEGAN, ISRAEL DEPUTIES
REFUSED THEIR MOST BASIC
DUTIES.
DEPUTY SCOTT PETERSON'S ONLY
JOB WAS TO PROTECT STUDENTS
AT THE SCHOOL HID WHILE CRUZ
MURDERED 17 PEOPLE.
WHEN THREE MORE BROWARD
DEPUTIES ARRIVED, THEY TOO
TOOK SHELTER BEHIND THEIR
CARS, RATHER THAN TRY AND
ENTER THE SCHOOL AND SAVE
THE LIVES OF CHILDREN.
SCOTT ISRAEL IS THE MAN IN
CHARGE OF ALL OF THIS AND,
OF COURSE, HE IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR IT.
HE LOUDLY DISAGREES, INDEED,
ISRAEL RELENTLESSLY BRAGS
ABOUT HIMSELF TO ALL MEDIA
WHO WILL RECORD IT.
TWO YEARS AGO FOR EXAMPLE
THE LOCAL NEWSPAPER IN
FLORIDA REPORTED THAT ISRAEL
USED TAX DOLLARS TO BUILD A
PERSONAL POLITICAL MACHINE
AND HE CLEARLY HAD.
THE EVIDENCE WAS THERE STONE
COLD.
CON FRONTED WITH IT ISRAEL
SAID THIS, QUOTE:  WHAT HAVE
I DONE DIFFERENTLY THAN DON
SHULA OR ABRAHAM LINCOLN OR
MARTIN LUTHER KING OR
GRANDE, END QUOTE AND BY THE
WAY HE SAID LIONS DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE OPINIONS OF SHEEP.
STABLE PEOPLE DON'T TALK
LIKE, THIS OBVIOUSLY.
SOMETHING IS WRONG WITH
SHERIFF ISRAEL.
AS RECENTLY AS YESTERDAY, HE
WAS REFUSING TO ACCEPT ANY
RESPONSIBILITY IN THE FACE
OF HIS WELL-DOCUMENTED
FAILURES.
WATCH THIS EXCHANGE.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT IF THE
BROWARD SHERIFF'S OFFICE HAD
DONE THINGS DIFFERENTLY THIS
SHOOTING MIGHT NOT HAVE
HAPPENED?
>> LISTEN, IF IFS AND BUTS
WERE CANDY AND NUTSOLOGIC
SINKS WOULD STILL BE IN THE
RECORD BOOKS.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
THERE IS 17 DEAD PEOPLE AND
A WHOLE LOT OF THINGS YOUR
DEPARTMENT COULD HAVE DONE
DIFFERENTLY.
>> Tucker: REMARKABLY, IT
GOT WEIRDER AND WORSE FROM
THERE.
WATCH.
>> ARE YOU REALLY NOT TAKING
ANY RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
MULTIPLE RED FLAGS THAT WERE
BROUGHT TO THE ATTENTION OF
THE BROWARD'S SHERIFF'S
OFFICE ABOUT THIS SHOOTER
BEFORE THE INCIDENT WHETHER
IT WAS PEOPLE NEAR HIM,
CLOSE TO HIM, CALLING THE
POLICE ON HIM?
>> JAKE, I CAN ONLY TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT I
KNEW ABOUT.
I EXERCISED AS MY DUE
DILIGENCE.
I HAVE GIVEN AMAZING
LEADERSHIP TO THIS AGENCY.
>> AMAZING LEADERSHIP?
>> I WORK -- YES, JAKE.
>> Tucker: AMAZING
LEADERSHIP.
AND, YET, THE FACTS SUGGEST